hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over a fun variation
for white
in the petrov defense which petrol
starts out with e4 e5
knight f3 knight to f6 and usually we
just assume that white's going to take
here on e5
and then black can play just the normal
uh d6 can play the stafford gambit
knight to c6 we've done videos on all of
these
but white has some fun variations as
well does not have to take the pawn here
on e5 so that's exactly what we're going
to be looking at today the variation
is called the boating kizidiki gambit
and that continues with bishop to
c4 now in the particular line we're
going to be looking at it's the accepted
line
and that is with the knight taking here
on e4
and we're gonna play knight to c3 so
this is the setup
if you guys want to see uh the decline
lines where the knight does not take at
the pawn here on e4
you can let me know if this video is
popular it
lets me know that this is an opening
that you are
wanting to see more of so i'll
definitely do more variations but i
think this is the most common
definitely the most exciting and if
you're not familiar with this variation
at all
i think it'll give you some ideas to
think about if you ever run into
the petrov defense so we'll go ahead and
get into it there are also going to be
multiple variations
in the description i will have a link if
you ever come back to this video and you
know
you want to hop ahead to a particular
variation
things we're going to be looking at
today are night taking here on
c3 black playing knight to c6
pawn to c6 and then lastly the knight
coming back here to
d6 so just giving you a heads up of what
we will be covering in
this video
so the first variation the most common
that you will see is the knight taking
here
on c3 white does need to recapture with
the pawn
here so white's down upon the material
henceforth
the gambit but you can start to see the
pressure that white has
the queen is activated it's controlling
the semi-open file here on the d
file it can easily get involved into the
game
once the knight moves to f3 g4 or
h5 putting a lot of pressure on the king
side
the light square bishop here is already
eyeing down and attacking this weakened
f7 square
the dark square bishop being involved
into the game very easily it's very easy
for white to castle
to either side the board depending on
where white continues
and black has no pieces that are
developed the only piece
that was developed was the knight and it
already moved three different squares it
moved here to f6
and then it moved here to e4 and then it
came to c3 and that's
exactly what white is playing for is to
give up that pawn and material
for a massive advantage in development
so you can see things are wide open
now it comes down to how is black going
to continue in this position so we'll
look at a few variations of how you
could see black
continue
i like to start by showing some of the
mistakes that the opponent can make so
that you can start to see the threats
that you actually have
in a particular opening so they may
think that knight to c6
is a strong move because right now black
is up material so they want to develop
material
as well as hold on to their material
advantage so this does exactly that
knight to c6
it brings the knight to the center of
the board it defends this pawn here on
e5 but this is going to be a massive
mistake because
knight 2 g5 the knight and the bishop
are both eyeing this
f7 square and there's no way to defend
this now they could get pretty creative
and play something like
pawn to uh d5 uh then bishop takes on
d5 still protected by the queen here
remember we opened up
this d-file for the queen to protect it
but after they play the pawn that does
open up the door for the bishop to come
here to e6
so that that does allow them to defend
it in some way but now we can just take
with our knights and after the pawn
takes
we can just take their knight here on a
c6
and as soon as their pawn captures here
we can play queen 2h5 we don't even have
to take their queen wide away
right away and as soon as their king
moves we can gobble up some material
right here so their king is in the
center of the board we can castle to
either side of the board here
we can get our bishop involved here
bishop two g5
is an extremely strong move right here
then castle on the queen
side if we want to get our rooks
activated our pawn structures are much
better than theirs
and you can see we're even up material
as far as
pawns are considered so this is
definitely going to be a very
strong move for white this may not
necessarily see that knight to c6 but in
case you do that would be a huge mistake
from black
so next option that you may see is pawn
to f6 and this is the strongest way to
defend this pawn but it also has its own
challenges because
here white can play knight 2
h4 with the threat of queen coming to
h5 if you want to see just how big that
threat is let's say they continue with
knight to c6 unaware of the threat
that's coming and they may think that
yeah if you play a queen to h5 i'll just
play my
pond right here to g6 it may not
recognize just how big the threat is
but we'll go ahead and show you so queen
2 h5 check
and you can probably see that they do
need to play
g6 because if they play king 2 e7 well
that's just going to be checkmate here
with knight 2
f5 so if they play g6
well first we can go ahead and take with
the knight here on at g6 and once this
knight moves
there's going to be a discovered attack
here on the king because the queen will
have opened up here so more than likely
they're gonna take with the pawn
it may look like that the queen can just
take
this rook here on h8 but there's
actually a much stronger move and you
can start to chase this king
all around the board and the move is
queen takes on
g6 you don't just want to gobble up
material you are looking to destroy
their entire setup right here so if you
start to look at
where can they go well the only move
right here is king to e7
and now you have queen to f7 and you can
see it's protected by the bishop right
here so we're limiting the squares that
the king can go
and then we have king to d6 so the king
is completely exposed in the center of
the board
and now the decisive move from white
is white can play bishop to g5
and this does a few things one it allows
for the rook to get involved into the
game if it wants to come to d1 so if
black says
yeah we'll just go and take this pawn
what a ridiculous move that is
okay well that's fine now the rook can
come here to d1
and things eventually will fall apart
and black will be checkmated
they're just running out of moves here
and white's just adding another
a strong attacker in this position
now we come back and say uh what if the
pawn doesn't take here
you can't just have bishop to e7 trying
to protect this pawn
because then you're just going to have a
pretty quick checkmate here with queen 2
d5 so that's definitely not going to
work
there's no real good option for black to
continue here
and so let's say they play uh
rook down to uh or maybe knight to
d4 just trying something well now the
bishop can just take here on f6
if this bishop's not being attacked and
now it's attacking both the queen
and the rook also the pawn's attacking
the knight right here but it really just
doesn't matter too much because there's
no good way
for black to continue so that's really
the pressure that you're putting on your
opponent
when you play that move with knight two
h4
and they do have to be very aware of
this because queen to h5
is a huge threat so if they see this
knight to h4
they should be playing immediately pawn
to g6
they do not want the queen to come here
to h5 that's too big of a threat
if they do play g6 then you can play
f4 remember they have no material
that is developed and so it's very
difficult for them to find
any sort of counter attack here all
they're doing is pushing up their pawns
further and further
and that's just more room for you to
attack their king and you have a lot
more pieces
involved into the action so if they take
here you can just recapture with your
bishop
which probably not going to be very good
for them because you now have two
bishops in the center of the board
you have a queen that's very active you
have a knight that's very active you can
get your rook involved you can castle on
the king side if you want to
they're probably not going to do that
but it's very difficult to find
the best continuation for them if you
look at what
you know people have recommended are the
best lines you see see things like queen
to e7
then white starts to push up and put
more pressure on the king side here
with f5 and then queen to g7 and then
the pawn takes then the pawn recaptures
queen to g4 but from black standpoint
how do you really find those moves
so while we are looking at optimal
strategy for black i also think it's
very difficult for them to find all the
right moves and because of that i think
this is one of the the best ways to play
this
particularly in an opening where i are
in a game where you may not have
a lot of time control it's just very
difficult if they're not familiar with
this opening which after this video you
will be to find all of these moves
last version we will look at in this
particular position is instead of
playing
f6 which i said is really the optimal
way if you want to hold on to that pawn
is if they try d6 and this is going to
be similar to if they played the knight
to c6
because white can play knight to g5
now they still have the bishop to e6 as
we talked about but we can just take
with our bishop
here and then after the pawn takes then
white has the threat of queen to
f3 this is a massive threat because not
only is it threatening the queen tier
to f7 for checkmate but let's say that
they decide
to play queen to e7 just saying yeah i'm
just stopping this threat right here
well now white can just play queen takes
on b7
and then the rook is going to fall here
on a8
and black's going to be down a ton of
material
i can castle to the king side have
safety
you can see the knight here on g5 is
protected by the bishop
this bishop here on f8 is completely
blocked in
this rook on h8 is not doing anything
this knight here on b8 is not doing
anything the rook on a is about to fall
you can see black is definitely
going to lose this game so that's all
the variations
uh that i think you'll be running into
with the knight taking here on c3
and then the pawn capturing here on c3
now while the most common variation is
with the knight taking here on c3 you
may not always see that
another option that you may see is
knight to
c6 and while it does look like that
leaves the knight here hanging on e4
uh black is able to get material back
because after knight takes on e4
then pawn can just come down to d5
forking the bishop and the knight and
they will be able to get back the
material
i still think this is the correct way
for white to continue by taking the
knight here on
e4 after they play the pawn
then i'd recommend playing bishop to d3
they
pretty much need to uh take with their
pawn
they could get try you know try to be
pretty creative with
uh pawn to f5 and then maybe after
the knight comes back then they push
forward and have
another fork here uh but i think they're
extending their pawns up a little
further than they would like so uh after
bishop to
d3 and they take here the bishop is
going to
recapture here and i think white has a
fine setup both sides are equal in
material
and let's say they play bishop to d6
getting ready to castle on the king side
white can castle
and it's very difficult to see how
white's in a tough position both sides
have one central pawn
white can easily push this pawn forward
to one of these central squares get the
dark square bishop involved into the
game bring the rook over here to e1
and both sides have the bishop pair both
sides have one knight
and so while this was a gambit and you
wanted to see what your opponent would
do
even if they played knight to c6 and
don't take your knight here on c3
you're still going to have a very solid
game
now in this position the important thing
to note is
this knight here on c6 protects the pawn
here on e5 and that's
that's critical because let's say that
they play pawn to
c6 because they kind of look at and say
okay well now the knight's just going to
come to e4
now i can push forward here i'm still
forking
both the bishop and the knight here so
what gives well what gives is if they
play
pawn to c6 white can first take here on
f7 it can disregard this knight here on
e4
after the king takes well then the
knight can take here
on e4 and then if you look at it yes
both sides are equal in material both
sides have
seven pawns both sides are equal
in the number of minor pieces although
black does have the
bishop pair but the king is completely
exposed i do like this better
than taking with your knight here you
may say you know kevin why don't you
just go ahead and take
this pawn here that's an extra pawn in
material
and this does check the king so the king
is forced to move but let's say the king
comes back here to g8
then you take with your knights here on
e4 and they play queen to e8 and just
gets tricky because
you're gonna lose one of these knights
let's say they play up
f4 here trying to protect this knight
well then you just have
a d6 and it becomes a challenge so i
wouldn't get too greedy
instead in this position i would just go
ahead and play
knight takes on e4 the king is already
exposed
it's going to be moving away or you're
going to be attacking it as well you can
still put a lot of pressure on
the central square you can castle on the
king side uh push your pawn forward here
on the d
file get your bishop involved and start
to attack
but this is gonna be very very good for
white so that's why they can't just play
c6
they do need to play that knight to c6
if they want to hold control
of this e5 square
the last variation we are going to look
at is if the knight comes back here to
d6 and from black standpoint i really
like
this variation it attacks the bishop
right here
the move from white i like is bishop to
d5 and the main reason for that is it
really does force the move
to c6 and then the bishop can come back
here to
b3 and then let's say they push forward
to e3
then we're just going to play queen to
e2 pinning down this pawn here
and then maybe queen to e7
and then knight to d4
and they really just becomes building up
around this pawn here
on e4 and eventually white should be
able to
get that material back i think it's
easier to attack it from this way
then if you immediately just come back
and play
bishop to b3 in this case
they can push forward with e4 and after
the knight moves let's say to
e5 they could play knight to c6
and then if we push forward here they
may take
we recapture here but you can see
we are down upon a material now we do
have a very open position and we can
start to attack in a lot of ways
but i do find it more difficult to gain
the advantage back
in this position than in the previous
example
so that's why i do like from black
standpoint that knight to d6
because i think it's more difficult for
white to really
find the advantage but that is the bkg
hopefully you guys
enjoyed this video on a way for white to
get creative
in the petrov defense if you would like
to see
more about this opening maybe the
decline lines
uh feel free to let me know in the
comments if you wouldn't mind hitting
that like button lets me know that you
support
both the channel and this video thank
you guys
so much for watching the video and i'll
see you in the next video